y aucun revenu dans trois épisodes du
coup de fil cette fois son mal être il y
a un truc de ouf
trop stylé qui déchire sa mère et ça
s'appelle le divertissement pascalien
[Musique]
c'est cool c'est un trône en c'est mieux
quand ça va vite
plutôt que quand ça va doucement vous ne
trouvez pas c'est normal quand je les
super vite avec plein d'animations
partout occupe l'attention ton cerveau
alors que quand ça va lentement balle
attention ton cerveau est libre et du
coup tu t'es fier et on déteste se faire
chier bah ouais des cons et sans rien
faire on se retrouve face à soi-même et
à des pensées négatives liées au fait
que je sois mortels comme par exemple
quel est le sens de ma vie ou qu'est ce
que je dois accomplir avant ma mort ou
encore il y at il une vie après la mort
quel est mon but dans la vie parce que
j'ai un destin
refus sur terre et nabila djahnine du
coup on va vouloir occuper notre
attention à quelque chose pour éviter
d'être dans ses théâtres penser et c'est
ça qu'on appelle le divertissement
pascalien ça nous vient de place pascal
menée en 1623 à clermont ferrand vie que
partout les clermontois en gros alors en
fait il voulait créer un livre qui
s'appelle l'apologie de la religion
chrétienne
[Musique]
mais il n'a pas pu parce que il est mort
avant donc on a récupéré toutes ses
pensées qu'il avait sur des petits bouts
de papier et on en a fait un livre
posthume qui s'appelle les pensées
imaginove un livre avec tes pensées toi
les pensées si on avait des bouchons au
bout des doigts est ce que la société
accepterait qu'on mange avec l'ennemi
pensez à nettoyer les cotons tiges pour
une seconde utilisation acheter
cassoulet pour l'assuré paie fait brice
pour l'after
et puis si jamais débordement pour
occuper vos intentions à quelque chose
je vais devoir trouver une activité
comme par exemple jouer ou mater du
porno mais pas seulement le
divertissement pascalien c'est aussi bas
aller en cours
faire de la physique et même travailler
pour gagner sa vie en fait c'est tout ce
qui nous évite de penser à des questions
existentielles
voilà enfin merci de préciser que la
science est aussi un divertissement et
qu'il n'ya pas que les pings
pornographie
ce qu'il faut éviter c'est de prendre
ces divertissements trop au sérieux et
d'oublier que derrière tout ça bahia
nous l'essentiel c'est vrai que certains
se perdent dans le jeu et donne aux
divertissements une place trop
importante par rapport à ce qu'ils
devraient avoir
je pense par exemple à tous ceux qui
sont criblées de dettes parce qu'ils ont
trop joué aux jeux d'argent même pire
ceux qui crèvent de mort les jeux vidéo
genre ce mec à taiwan qui a joué pendant
23 heures à league of legends et qui est
mort de man devant loeb voilà le mec n'a
même pas eu le temps de finir sa
grenadine 1
alors je sais pas si c'est à cause du
jeu mais il a aussi un peu crispé elle
est mort quand se donnent ces
divertissements on se crée une illusion
pour éviter de penser à tous ces trucs
chiants pascal appelle ça ce pipe et
encore oui apparemment ça se fait
facilement en se cassant les deux côtes
et dès qu'on a fini un divertissement on
va le remplacer par un autre
c'est pour ça qu'on adore les playlists
par exemple un peu comme un signe pas
quant à elle à sa femme tout va bien il
est averti et puis quand elle crève
avons regardé attire de nouveau
oui les tic la mezam single again le
pouvoir de l'imagination peut nous aider
aussi énormément avec divertir je suis
sûr que vous êtes déjà fait tellement
fier que vous avez regardé les nuages
une fois et que vous leur avez donné des
noms en fonction de leur forme est la
vôtre pas que ce nuage on dirait un
dauphin vite et avec ces yeux là un
dauphin c'est vraiment [ __ ] toit d'une
grosse sobre mais pas du tout ça
ressemble à un gros caca à du caca
personnes nouveau le cas ici du coup se
divertir se met défunte un peu c'est pas
bien en fait c'est fait c'est pas bien
le truc c'est que pascal dit lui-même
que sans divertissement n'y a pas de
joie
donc c'est essentiel pour l'homme de se
divertir
or se divertir et se détourner de
l'essentiel
donc c'est essentiel de se détourner de
c'est ce qu'on appelle un paradoxe par
contre ce qui est mauvais pour pascal
c'est pour le divertissement trop au
sérieux et se perdent dedans et c'est ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
après faut savoir que parce qu'elle
n'est pas le premier à en avoir parlé il
ya aussi sénèque mais parce qu'elle
apporte une grosse dimension chrétienne
qu'on n'a pas du tout vu dans cette
vidéo mais je préfère vous le dire merci
beaucoup pour vos encouragements ça fait
vachement plaisir j'ai créé un compte
twitter hésitez pas à aller voir où je
dis par exemple où j'en suis dans la
création de mes vidéos alors si vous
voulez suivre un petit peu ou si vous
voulez prendre acte et ce peut être plus
facile en attendant n'hésitez pas à
passer le couple est un ami c'est à dire
partager cette vidéo on se retrouve pour
une prochaine fois pour un prochain
épisode pour un proche un coup de fil